[Music]
in misleading label views what the [ __ ]
that's every fast-food chain oh yes I
like who do you mean every fast-food
chain let's move on like in and out
let's move off start misleading I don't
know she always says some offensive [ __ ]
I just like every time you forget open
your mouth and I just want to put my
[ __ ] fist in your teeth here you're
better than your blood that's good yeah
I can't do that my foots too clean with
it I don't know why like move on her
submitted by belly Bongo Bella Bella
bangle was Bella bond oh hello self
total enticement how are your two
Blancos Jelly Belly is being sued by a
woman claims she didn't know Jelly Belly
jelly beans contain sugar right well we
should sir for a [ __ ] dumbass
turbidity how does she not know that
jellybeans didn't contain sugar so what
is I didn't know I thought it had milk
particular but a jelly bean I thought it
was just jelly bean I thought it was
jelly and [ __ ] red bean so jessica
Gomes from the San Bernardino County
oh no you cannot be in California and be
buying it can you explain why this
Mexican now defend or Syrian people it
has nothing to do with you see it has
everything to do with the parenting hey
hey when asian people [ __ ] up
we've always blamed the race yeah if you
have to blame the rain-filled
yep so she filed a class action lawsuit
class action yes for fraud negligent
misrepresentation and product liability
so she's claiming that doctors should
get a class action law what I'm thinking
so she's a she's claiming that
Jellybelly tricked her into into buying
their 14 sports B so I didn't even know
they had this product this is what it
looks like
so the way they market it it's like that
it has cards electrolytes vitamin C and
C get energizes you and like they're
marketing it more for like athletes
that's [ __ ] crazy the nutrition is in
the back right yes then she's a [ __ ]
idiot
so the way they're promoting it too is
that it's a diet supplement
scientifically formulated to fuel the
body and helps burn fat that's the way
they're marketing this and so they're
labeling on the package sugar as these
evaporated cane juice um it's false or
misleading because it suggests that the
sweetener is juice or it's made from
juice and I did not reveal that it is
basic it's baby back worry that's
actually not actually the definition of
service actually not misleading at all
and it's actually being more transparent
and they need to be it tells you what
were the sugars coming from or the
training is saying that it's misleading
that it's not in [ __ ] sorry strippers
that's what I'm yeah no I'm sure I'm
with you but yeah so that's what the
attorney saying and so the package it
says she also notes the the differences
on labeling because on the package it
says cane juice and on the ingredient
list and it shows that it's 17 grams of
sugar on the nutrition facts table on
the website the ingredients list says
cane sugar and it shows 19 grams of
sugar on the nutrition table so there's
like totally different information from
the website in the package so that's
already like basis that's not roughly 20
grams of sugar yeah there's still sugar
in there that's the the foundation in
the basis for her suing there's like 30
different types of sugars that they put
into foods processed foods it's so many
different ways like even molasses like
that's a type of sugar if you see it in
the product and you go okay when you're
reading the ingredients and you can read
anything like high fructose next Becca
dextrose not anything ending in house
this is her family
nectar corn syrup solids lacks
extra small you're all awesome setting
sugars and they're real sugars whatever
is available to that country that's what
they're going to make the sugar from so
in Europe they usually have used like
beet sugar and the states it's corn
sugar sugar the body must have Eliza's
the same work but no I actually doesn't
metabolize the same way because
high-fructose corn syrup is a way more I
don't know it's harder to break down
than just regular cane sugar
apparently the motion read this is
nonsense no reasonable consumer could
have been deceived by sports beans
labelings jessica Gomes could not have
seen evaporated cane juice without also
seeing a project sugar content on it
nutritional and personal I hope this
girl loses a lot of money for this just
going for all the legal proceedings and
I hope she ends up poor and on the
streets well the project class-action
lawsuit is the lawyer take that firm
deciding to take it on and then they
email everyone who bought the thing and
then they ask you want to be a part of
this [ __ ] because I can see how people
like they look at the front of the label
and then they're mislead there where
it's like sports performance and then
it's like it fuels you and all that and
I think people all coulis must be good
for you there's electrolyte and you hear
all these like key buzzwords that are
supposed to be good for you but I think
people forget to like self reflect and
they go well what are my feelings
gilding me sitting on the couch watching
TV then obviously you're taking way too
much carbs than the amount of activity
that you're doing I think for an athlete
that's training crazy and they need a
ton of carbs that is actually the truth
it will fuel them but for her I'm
assuming she probably isn't an athlete
and she's just chilling so you don't
need to fuel your chill so you should
turn it around and see what actually is
behind there and if there's almost 20
grams of sugar per serving that's a lot
I don't think people even know the
amounts of sugar they should even be
taking you know what I do agree with her
though is the whole like misleading
sports [ __ ] alright do we got this new
slurping coming out it's like the
[ __ ] weight loss Slurpee and it only
has 80 grams of sugar
woah weight loss Slurpee and everyone
starts taking it in like diet coke all
that [ __ ] I don't like that because it
kind of preys upon people that's crazy
to NATO because it's like you're going
to eat these sports Joe
because you thought it didn't contain
any sugar at all like what the [ __ ] you
all know that sugar makes you fat what I
guess that makes you fat or six sports
jellybeans I think there's I mean it's a
blurry line if I were what sport do you
play but they're done but the stupidity
isn't in this they read sports
jellybeans and they're like it's not
going to have any sugar that's their
assumption that's what she was saying
they won't have any sugar no that's what
she assumed that yeah that's what that's
what's misleading is yeah the evaporated
cane juice is what was misleading for
her but they see that's ridiculous
though like that's her assumption though
and then there's also something where
shows how many grams of sugar is in
there I can't believe a lawyer actually
took this case because honestly like
before I got into like actually
understanding nutrition and just hiding
like I wouldn't have been I wouldn't
have known like when I would read
practice as I said fat free I only
thought that made you fat I didn't know
that you know sugar turns into fat
making you fat dude I mean I never
thought like that like sugar made you
fat like no sugar was bad for you that's
likely that it was bad for your teeth I
didn't know it was bad overall health
wise yeah well at least I didn't know at
least in California though I think
everyone is taught that the daily
recommended calorie allowance is roughly
2,000 for an adult yeah so I think it is
also up to your own due diligence to at
least like you don't have to like track
your calories but just any given day you
can kind of ballpark and I think that's
where people gauge like fats through the
wall that's 1500 calories in one meal so
don't eat McDonald's every day and I
think there's this general like general
like notion that people understand so I
think like if you look at 20 grams and
you're like oh [ __ ] that's probably
going to be I gotta know like 300
calories or something like yeah that's
that's I don't know I felt like that was
the average person and I have but there
was a there was a craze that went down
in the 90s and everything became
fat-free and people are still living
with that mindset today
yeah and they thought that you know if
you eat something that was fat-free it
was better for your diet and all that
but what these manufacturers did is to
make sure that the food still tasted
good they took away the fat but they
added sugar because they realize that
food with they call it a Bliss point
there's a level of how much
sugar makes us really happy and it makes
our dopamine come out and all that and
it's in almost all processed foods so
every process you didn't know yeah they
use chemists and then they have a Bliss
point even orange juice fruit juice all
that stuff they have that because it
sells people are addicted to it and they
don't know that it makes them fast so
with that I'm actually down with her
even though she's [ __ ] dumb as [ __ ]
I think people should make companies
more accountable for what's in their
product and [ __ ] like that because
people don't know cuz I would see my mom
she was she was all on this like
slimfast craze like back in the 90s
everyone was on slim fast and then once
I started getting more to nutrition and
it'll actually looked at the nutrition
facts I was like a whole [ __ ] it's that
crazy bad for you not only is your shits
in the chemicals but then the sugar to
fat content is like no wonder she's not
losing weight because it's like she
doesn't understand what she's putting in
her body you know about what she needs
to do that for now so a lot of these
companies are like in my company's
argument not that I agree with these
companies they actually put instructions
because they're bound by law so the
slimfast
on the back assist this is a meal
replacement for one meal the problem is
people are still having to three meals
drinking that thing in there in
moderation so they're mister misusing
the product I think that when products
do state fat-free they're not lying
it is literally fast we do put a ton of
sugar but there it's still fat-free so I
think you still have to do your own due
diligence I think maybe what they can do
is like the surgeon general's warning
whether like hey the daily sugar
consumption should be this is 20 grams
above what you should be taking maybe
they could do something to help notify
the public yeah but a lot of these
packaging and companies are not really
lying from their point of view company
is what they should do is develop a pill
that allows broccoli to taste like pizza
yes and then I would just be [ __ ]
broccoli wasted I don't like that magic
fruit right what point you brought me
every day for every meal probably not
everybody goes I'm just saying those
tiny buckets I could have
like let's say broccoli green beans
right and then like this dry a screaming
chicken breast and I take this powder
and you put over at a Thai chili cheese
fries BAM
I've been like - man I cannot get enough
of this garbage boom like Oh God ah it'd
be so great
well Jamie's fans I hope you guys liked
that video once again remember if you
want to be involved just submit some
article them I'll suck your dick
now but seriously though there's more
videos up there
[Music]
you